[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui il est président de la
république avec donc c'est ce qui était
très proche de lui le sont
nécessairement un peu moins cela va
faire ma rentrée très chargée mais vous
savez bien à eux y ait un lien
indéfectible et celui de l'amitié qui
reste toujours
donc amis nous mettions et on le restera
j'espère un ami de macron mais un ami
que le président a mis dans la panade en
voulant faire de lui un candidat aux
marches présidence normale vie privée
livre de confidences désormais libre de
parole gaspard ganzer conseiller en com
à l'elysée revient pour nous sur les
crises qui ont émaillé le mandat de
françois hollande est donné ce qu'ils
pensent de la stratégie choisie par
emmanuel macron entre rupture affichée
est contrainte de la fonction cette
semaine dans déshabillons-les le
conseiller en com des habits le
président kaspar hauser bonjour bonjour
alors nous sommes de prokop à une
brasserie du quartier latin non loin de
la brasserie désormais célébrissime
rotonde voilà célèbre depuis la fête de
victoires qui organise et emmanuel
macron après avoir fait le v de la
victoire on s'en souvient sur scène au
soir du premier tour alors qu'il devait
rassembler face à marine le pen
c'était une erreur de communication
selon vous à moi je n'étais pas ce soir
là je n'étais pas invitée à la ronde un
moment je n'étais pas invitée à la
rotonde ce que j'étais avec le prénom de
la république sortant le précédent donc
françois hollande
je pense que ça a été le meilleur moment
la campagne présidentielle est en
réalité les journalistes ont voulu y
voir un parallèle entre une autre
célébration de victoire d'auch deuxième
pour quelques années au précédent et ça
parce que je pense il pense qu'il avait
sous-estimé est donc très vite il a
corrigé
et puis on a retenu dans les jours qui
ont suivi d'autres séquences qui pourra
la poule etc qui sont venus écrasé entre
guillemets cette séquence qui n'était
pas la meilleure de la campagne à la
meilleure mais donc écrasa bhl entre
guillemets par d'autres j'espère je
crois oui je crois je crois pas que
c'est quelque chose dont on leur parlera
pendant longtemps alors juste une petite
chose me dit j'espère alors ça pose
quand même la question et ce sera une
édition
les mots emmanuel macron vous le
connaissez bien vous avez pu vous l'avez
côtoyé quand vous étiez chargé
munication à l'elysée et secrétaire
général anouar où il est aujourd'hui
vous êtes proche de lui ou pas tant que
ça alors aujourd'hui il est président de
la république et donc c'est ce qui était
très proche de lui le sont
nécessairement un peu moins parce qu'il
a beaucoup de choses à faire ma rentrée
très chargée mais vous savez il ya un
lien indéfectible qui est celui de
l'amitié qui reste toujours
donc amis nous l'étions amis nous et
nous délections aujourd'hui nous le
restons et on le restera j'espère et
puis moi je serai toujours là pour
l'aider s'il a besoin de moi même si
voilà mis non il ya ce grand destin qui
se dessine devant lui et comme moi je
vais mener d'autres projets d'accord
donc pas de question pour vous de
collaborer avec lui
non ça je pense que il n'a pas envisagé
je n'ai pas envisagé non plus parce que
je pense que c'est parce était pas
forcément la meilleure configuration à
la fois parce que moi j'avais déjà
travaillé avec le président de la
république précédents
et puis en plus je suis pas sûr qu'on
est très bon conseiller quand on est
amis de la personne que l'on conseille
alors parce que je dirais qu'en matière
de communication en tout cas il veut
rompre enfin on al impression puisqu'il
a une idée très précise de ce qu'il veut
faire
et alors contrairement à ce qu'on avait
vu dans les précédents mandats avec
cette cette accélération dictée par les
médias qui sont mes s'être imposé au
président lui veut être comme il dit un
maître des horloges
est ce que ça vous paraît possible je
pense qu'il a raison de dire qu'il veut
faire différemment ça c'est
incontestable parce que tout président
veut rompre avec la communication son
prédécesseur nicolas sarkozy avait
cherché à rompre avec celle de jacques
chirac on est entré comme ça très
présent médiatiquement et c'est françois
hollande elle ou il rompre avec celle de
nicolas sarkozy en inspirons de la
normalité en excluant la normalité et
même macron veut rompre avec la
communication de françois hollande en
dix ans qui va peut-être maintenir à la
presse plus à distance par les plus plus
avec plus de distance moins souvent en
tout cas je pense il a raison de le dire
va-t-il pouvoir le faire ça c'est la
question
je crois que là le monde médiatique a
profondément changé notre rapport au
temps a aussi largement changé et un
président qui ne parle pas pendant trois
jours c'était possible il ya 30 ans
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est quasiment
impossible parce que déjà les affaires
du monde s'impose en permanence à la
france et on a attendu pendant la
république il y réagissent d'autre part
les médias sont voraces de réaction
d'information et car le présent à public
est pas obligé de tout commenté de
réagir à tout mais sa parole est attendu
et j'observe que dans les premiers jours
du quinquennat des ménages macron il a
finalement parlé assez souvent ouais
enfin même temps il a fait attendre
alors vous dites sur les médias voraces
ils avaient commenté lui-même dans
certaines interviews avant son élection
dans l'est mais les médias sont voraces
et une espèce de monstre qui veut du
temps avoir à manger justement il faut
pas lui donner il disait il faut pas
nourrir comme ça là la bête médiatique
quand vous dites c'est bien de dire vous
pensez qu'il ne peut pas le faire que
c'est impossible je pense qu'il faut le
public c'était impossible je pense qu'on
peut le faire de façon différente mais
moi je crois pas qu'il ya la question ce
soit est ce qu'on parle trop ou pas
assez
la question s'il faut parler au bon
moment il ya des situations de crise
dans lesquelles la parole du trait noir
et public est extrêmement attendu
pendant des attentats on attend qu'ils
parlent souvent pour exprimer la
situation l'expliquer etc et période
plus calme dans lequel sa part les moins
attendus sauf peut-être pour guider
donner une orientation alors autre
certitude un vous l'avez dire chacun
chaque président veut rompre avec le
précédent
on va voir ça n'a pas toujours été
couronnées de succès alors oui lui veut
rompre avec le président normal un cac
qui a été françois hollande il a
théorisé aussi est-ce que c'est pas une
erreur justement de vouloir toujours se
positionner par rapport à son
prédécesseur
je pense qu'il faut un peu se
positionner par rapport à son
prédécesseur on a toujours intérêt
incarner une rupture un changement pour
ça je pense qu'il faut le faire
d'après assez vite faut dépasser cela
parce que dès qu'on est élu les gens
oublient qui a été votre prédécesseur
enfin n'oublie pas réellement mais ont
finalement s'intéresse à ce que vous
faites vous donc il faut être soi même
et je crois que dans la présidence
normale
il y avait aussi des très bonnes choses
la simplicité et l'honnêteté la
proximité et je crois qu'ils monnayent
macron aussi jupitérien qu'il veut être
il a intérêt aussi à conserver ce qui a
aussi fait sa force c'est à une très
grande proximité avec les français
- ma séquence préférée l'élection
présidentielle c'est quand emmanuel
macron va parler avec les salariés de
world poule mais écoutez vous croyez pas
si bien dire mais c'est justement la
prochaine c'est quoi la suisse avait
tort c'est la séquence que je voulais
vous montrer ma alors justement ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'il ya cette
image ou mal amendements des salariés et
il ya aussi la lecture qu'ils ont fait
qu'on a pu voir dans un documentaire
diffusé sur tf1 je vous remonterez
l'extrait est enlacé intéressant parce
que la séquence commence à la chambre de
commerce plutôt feutré mais l'atmosphère
qu'il trouve trop feutré et il s'énerve
et je vous montre elle est repartie elle
appartient à la partie du parti
en assurer la détresse ne soyez pas du
tout moi même je demande de chaussée
disponible en fessionnels que les gangs
garden un mec donc mais vérifie rien et
rona depuis quelques jours le discours
était une unité pour ce soir le truc là
de déplacement n'était pas démonté
ajouté franchement je ne peux pas j'ai
senti tout de suite si elle est partie
restée vingt et un à québec sont
maintenant mais parce qu'on était pour
jour j'avais pas compris c'est fini je
ne veux pas paraître manquer je vais y
arriver là ce matin j'ai vu le truc en
bagnole je me suis tout de suite c'est
pas possible il ya 100 mecs devant moi
je passe les grilles du jardin ccg
jamais fait ça de ma près de sécurité
mais les mecs de la sécurité c'est pas
beau il faut écouter je ne serai jamais
en sécurité parce que le pays
et donc voilà il faut prendre le risque
folle et dans le coeur de la bête à
chaque fois donc le coeur de la bête
livres qui font d'elle parce que si vous
écoutez une vague d'insécurité
peut-être que cette insécurité fait
sourire plusieurs formules qui sont qui
sont amusantes
non je pense que ce qui est vraiment
intéressé il ya plusieurs choses
intéressantes dans cette séquence là la
première c'est le fait de se rendre à
liverpool
il a raison d'y aller à ce moment là
c'était pas prévu il rebondit ça c'est
excellent et surtout il décembre si on
prend la métaphore jupitérienne il
descend de l'olympe lille va sur terre
et je pense que c'est le corps oui mais
de danse arriver ouais mais non cette
idée je pense qu'il était déjà dans
cette posture de ce téléphone est très
verticale et il va sur le terrain et il
a raison et je pense que dans sa
présidence il aurait intérêt à faire de
même la deuxième chose c'est toujours
particulier parce que dans ce genre de
documentaire
on se demande toujours quel est le
niveau de conscience d'un conscience de
la présence de la caméra
donc non je sais ça on se pose toujours
la question il donc il doit certainement
oscillé entre entre les deux et on ne
peut pas s'empêcher de vous poser la
question de à quel moment ils y pensent
à quel moment il n'y pense pas ça c'est
très difficile de le savoir je pense
qu'il y pense souvent
ma conviction profonde à ils dépensent
en engueulant ses équipes entre
guillemets moi je crois que pensent en
disant si vous ce que c'est ça aussi si
vous écoutez des mecs de la sécurité
vous finissez comme hollande vous êtes
mort quoi on va venir seule chose sur ce
coup là mais je crois enfin c'est votre
métier là moi même je suis filmé par des
caméras on n'oublie jamais totalement la
caméra on se comprend pas la même
manière surface de télévision avec une
caméra à côté de soi que quand on est
chez soi dans son canapé c'est une
évidence surtout quand des incréments
professionnels comme mails macron les
donc doit toujours y penser après on n'y
est pas obsédé par la caméra ne fait pas
de la politique des petits 20 ans
oui je pense que c'est quelqu'un de
quelques jours quand même été attentif à
ce qu'il faisait après sur la question
de la sécurité je pense que là aussi la
raison de se dire qu'il faut pas
simplement voir les choses au nom de la
sécurité sinon fait absolument plus rien
après une fois qu'on est pendant la
république il faut pas oublier que on ne
s'appartient pas totalement non plus
on est présent de la république et que
donc le prix non république entend
fonction doit être protégée et on doit
aussi faire attention à ce que dit la
sécurité quoi d'accord pas ce qu'est la
sécurité effectivement on va dire
physique il ya la sécurité par rapport
aux images et on entend ça aussi un
petit peu et on a l'impression que c'est
aussi là dessus qui veut se capte tacle
aussi vis à vis de hollande a été à ce
contact est là peut-être ça peut vous
vous sentirez entre guillemets concernés
ou au lait noir visé moi je pense qu'il
faut toujours on peut toujours aller
davantage au contact je pense que quand
on devient prendra public
j'imagine j'imagine on a tendance à se
dire qu'il faut faire attention
permanence à l'image que l'on renvoie de
l'institution je crois que l'époque est
aussi à la prise de risques contact
direct avec les gens et je pense que
emmanuel macron devenu prendre la public
aura intérêt à conserver cela ce contact
direct avec les gens
françois hollande a ça en lui bah oui
j'aimerais vous dis à françois hollande
est ce qu'il n'y a pas moins fait à la
fin tu es trop peu fait quand c'était
devenu compliqué en termes de popularité
je pense que le melody d'ailleurs macron
non mais après on verra on verra comment
ça se passe mais pendant les cinq ans je
pense que françois hollande est chaud et
la préoccupation de le faire et moi je
me suis déplacé partout en france avec
lui pendant trois ans et avec ce jour
d'ailleurs un accueil qui était plutôt
bon il ya eu deux moments délicats
difficile pour des raisons totalement
différentes
un moment avant j'arrive moi qui étais
la manif pour tous compte donc la
manifestation contre le mariage pour
tous où là il y avait vraiment une
agressivité considérable sur tout le
territoire
partout où il allait il ya toujours cinq
six sept pistes et pas beaucoup de gens
mais c'était très agressif et c'est vrai
que d'un produit médiatique ce n'est pas
simple à gérer parce que les médias
peuvent avoir tendance à retenir la
seule personne qui siffle alors qu'il ya
500 personnes qui vous applaudissent
donc ça s'est il faut savoir apprendre à
gérer ça puis après les attentats s'il
faut pas oublier ça le prénom la
république ait dû faire attention dans
ses déplacements
parce que tout ce déplacement devait
être très sécurisée parce que
les terroristes on voulait à sa peau
notamment mais celle des autres pans du
bien de moi aussi je vais faire
attention
alors à propos d'imagés contrôle des
images et une séquence qui restera dans
les noms des annales c'est celle de la
visite à une jeune retraitée près de
nancy
et après il y avait eu une
déconstruction par les journalistes
justement est-ce que c'est pas ça aussi
l'absence de risques je vous montre
voilà ma j'officiais lucette brochet au
côté de françois hollande dans le salon
de son deux pièces
pas franchement à tête à tête parce
qu'autour d'eux il y avait des
journalistes et une très belle brochette
de ministres et d'élus locaux
un président la rencontre des vrais gens
la scène est aussitôt relayé sur les
réseaux sociaux par le conseiller en
communication du président il est là à
côté du frigo
le président françois hollande chez
lucette à vandoeuvre la rencontre avec
lucette était si importante que la vidéo
a même été mise en ligne par les
communicants de l'elysée
[Musique]
tout allait bien jusqu'à ce que nos
confrères de bfm rencontre lui cette
prochaine
alors c'est qui monsieur café c'est un
gars de la mairie le café c'est vous qui
l'avez préparer auparavant chez lui 1
il a tout fait à côté il avait emmené
les termes ans tout c'est les vôtres
mois n'ont même pas il a tout mais vous
avez acheté une belle fleur pour
l'occasion pour moi c'est pareil c'est
la mairie et il nous a dit de la mettre
sur la table
voilà lucette avait des choses à dire à
françois hollande
mais on en a empêchés il s'occupait
beaucoup d'immigrés mais pas deux les
clochards qui me crève ont pour ainsi
dire une chose dans la rue mais ça il
fallait pas je le dise qui vous a dit de
ne pas le dire
bah le cas de l'île d'ici là les gars de
l'elysée parce qu'il faut bah c'est pas
brillant non je pense qu'on peut pas
tout réussir dans un quinquennat c'est
l'anti vers le pool quoi oui bien sûr
enfin le jeu passionnant thibault en
tout cas c'est vrai que c'est pas le bon
en tout cas c'est en tout cas c'est pas
bon parce qu'en réalité dos des
déplacements et pendant la nuit qu'on en
a fait vraiment très très très grand
nombre de trois à quatre fois par
semaine
à chaque fois il ya des visites
officielles et visite officieuse on va
voir les gens chez eux et c est là à
chaque fois c'est filmé par les caméras
à tout ça et finalement très classique
et n'est pas très original est en fait
là il s'est passé quelque chose de
totalement inattendu s'est visiblement
madame brochet qui est une personne qui
habite dans le quartier sympathique
positive et c'est a été un peu trop
briefé en amont
par les gens sur place en tout cas
visible non importe voilà parce
qu'effectivement sur la question de la
spontanéité de la prise de risque et
c'est vrai que moi aussi moi j'avais su
ça va rudement on n'aurait pas eu à
gérer les choses de cette manière là
quoi d'accord donc c'est pas ça veut
dire c'est pas ce ne sont pas les
coulisses des déplacements tel qu'il se
passe de manière quotidienne c'est un
c'est un loupé qui n'était pas à l'image
des autres déplacements c'est ça
normalement c'est non ça reste des
déplacements du prix andré public des
personnes qui prévaudra publics ne sont
pas spontanés oui ce que je veux dire
c'est surtout quand il ya des caméras
l'après de la seule présence d'une
caméra gomme une grande partie de la
spontanéité d'un déplacement ou d'un
événement donc je vous crois pas aux
miracles la spontanéité devant une
caméra de télévision ça je n'y crois pas
après il faut que les choses soient
vraies et authentiques et ce qui est
gênant dans cette séquence c'est que
vivement madame brochet qui n'avait rien
demandé à personne
on lui a apporté du café des fleurs
d'accord en amont et ça je pense qu'il
faut pas faire et voyez vous laisser les
gens parler librement
moi je me suis retrouvé en plein de
situations pas toujours très simple avec
le prénom la république parce que
justement on avait laissé les choses se
faire naturellement
et finalement toujours une vérité une
vérité qui est ressorti à une autre
séquence dans un documentaire un peu
plus en cinq et d'une véracité
extraordinaire c'est que dans le film de
2,2 ni violent sur les la troisième
partie porte sur les attentats et une
séquence j'en reviens toujours pas que
finalement ils étaient filmés ils
veulent en soit encore une famille ah
ouais la famille des amis merabet mais
là je peux vous dire qu'on est dans la
vérité pure de ce qui s'est passé c'est
d'ailleurs qu'on revoie les images
moi j'avoue que je les revois jeu
incroyablement ému par ce que fait c'est
incroyable on est quelques jours après
la mort dans la mer abeille jeu long et
avait une très grande distance en fait
il fit de très loin pour pas être
intrusif et on voit ces discussions très
digne entre une mère très courageuse qui
vient de perdre son fils qui a beaucoup
d'admiration pour lui et c'est donc
voilà ça lui je préfère c'est retenir
ses vérités là que d un côté look
eighties indications c'est ça qui est
intéressant que ça c'est un loupé c'est
pas c'est pas le quotidien renoncer ça
d'accord c'est raté quelle était votre
mission alors qu'est ce qu'ils
fabriquent et raté tout ce qui est
fabriqué et rater ça
alors qu'elle était de votre mission à
qu'avez vous apporté ou françois
hollande en tant que responsable de la
communication françois hollande vous
avez rejoint en 2014 alors vous allez
répondre mais d'abord je vais vous
soumettre le commentaire de franck
louvrier alors qu'ils buvaient a occupé
pendant cinq ans aux côtés de nicolas
sarkozy et qui commente votre rapport à
la communication de françois hollande et
puis 2-3 de trois choses sur sa
communication aussi je vous montre ne
glisse pas à recadrer les choses
il n'a peut-être pas pu obtenir tout ce
qu'ils souhaitaient obtenir mais je
pense qu'il a réussi quand même à
canaliser certaines choses même si
parfois il n'a pas maîtriser totalement
ce qui était le film d'yves violent où
il était l'acteur principal alors que
l'acteur principal avec le chef de
l'état
mais je pense qu'il a essayé d'organiser
les choses et puis d'expliquer que la
communication c'était aussi du
professionnalisme en même temps le bilan
de françois hollande il est quand même
jugé assez négativement par les français
donc la nuit même par le même voilà
parce qu'il s'est pas représenté alors
là vous voyez de la communication n'a
pas réussi certains disent voilà c'est
celui qui n'a pas réussi à sauver
françois hollande de lui-même c'est vrai
que l'échec est mort il est indéniable
mais c'est pas due uniquement à la
communication
alors qu'est ce qu'on dirait de françois
fillon
ça a été encore plus grave échec et là
ça a été en partie à cause de la
communication parce que sur le fond il
maîtrisait parfaitement bien les choses
mais si vous voulez dans la
communication il faut savoir c'est comme
la changer il ya des métiers il y en a
pas un seul
vous avez la chirurgie esthétique puis
vous avez la chirurgie de guerre est
bien dans la communication vous avez la
communication de crise et puis vous avez
la communication d'exercice du pouvoir
c'est deux choses un peu différentes
qu'il faut savoir associer pendant cinq
ans beaucoup des crises avant l'intrigué
mais sous françois hollande notamment la
sortie du livre du fameux guide des
vélos nous l'avons pour le coup je crois
qu'à spa monza n'était pas dans la
boucle il a découvert après coup c'était
quelque chose qui avait été initié par
le président dès le début de son mandat
elle a été gérée comment selon vous
cette communication s'ils n'avaient pas
eu d'intervention du cher c'est sans
doute été l'une des raisons du fait que
françois hollande soit pas représenté
c'est arrivé à un moment où les chiffres
étant là la situation politique et
anglars et ce livre arrive en ont
par-dessus tout ça a fait sont
bouleversés un moment de la vie
politique française
hélas une fois que le livre était là
est-ce que selon vous c'était
rattrapable en matière de communication
parce qu'effectivement il a fait le
choix parce que c'est un choix personnel
un choix ses communicants de ne pas
intervenir à ne pas commenter la sortie
de ce livre de laisser m est difficile
de faire pousser du gazon sur du sable
quand la situation est finie
malheureusement c'est la théorie du sur
accident ça ne se fait que se multiplier
et quand donc mais austère à ce moment
là je pense que le livre a été une
erreur de la part du chef de l'état et
alors il ya eu deux axes qui ont été mis
en avant dans la communication poste
gaspard ganzer ça a été d'une part
l'idée de représidentialiser françois
hollande qui s'était un peu d
présidentialiser avec à travers toute
une série de cérémonies de commémoration
et notamment à l'été 2014 et puis après
je veux savoir ce que vous pensiez de
cette stratégie
je pense que c'est
d'une certaine façon un exercice très
compliqué parce que la
présidentialisation elle existe mais
elle a été beaucoup diminué par le
rythme et notamment du passage du
septennat au quinquennat
donc ça sert à rien alors de faire ça a
commémoré pour repris en mai un site
indispensable de commémorer mais ne
pensez pas que ça vous apporte un point
supplémentaire dans l'opinion
c'est normal c'est votre rôle c'est je
dirais votre rôle qui vous est imposé
maintenant ce qu'on vous demande c'est
des résultats il ya eu la question de la
communication autour de la vie privée
on a beaucoup reproché à nicolas sarkozy
d'avoir trop communiqué sur sa vie
privée s'est passé quelque chose que
vous contrôliez personnellement par
contraste françois hollande l'a beaucoup
moins fait il a très peu communiqué sur
sa vie privée même autant les images
fortes ça a été le président son scooter
si c'est pas une image de vie privée
pour m'expliquer ce que c'était pas de
la com et mai mais la réalité c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de frontières dans ce
type de responsabilité entre vie privée
et vie publique
le prends le chef de l'état appartient
tout le monde les médias ne se suffisent
pas des images officielles
ils veulent encore à connaître d'autant
plus vous voyez l'ensemble des
couvertures quasi people de l'actuel
président de la république et ce n'est
pas fini
ça sera toujours comme ça c'est ce qui
fait que on s'use beaucoup plus vite en
politique parce que on est surexposé et
la frontière entre vie publique et vie
privée n'existe plus récents ouais
l'affronter sur la vie privée d'ailleurs
c'est vrai que ça c'est intéressant
parce que pour le coup il ya une vraie
différence entre françois hollande et de
la sarkozie françois hollande qui n'a
quasiment jamais communiqué sur sa vie
privée du noir volontairement non mais
je pense qu'ils qu'on le prétend la
république précédents françois hollande
considère que la vie privée doit rester
privé maintenant ce n'est pas possible
ils disent que c'est sa vision c'est sa
vision des choses et elle est évidemment
respectable il n'est pas écrit dans un
article de la constitution que le prénom
la république doivent communiquer sur sa
vie privée
cet écrit nulle part il est élu lui
personnellement à la après la question
c'est est ce que c'est possible
et oui vous qui l'avez conseiller
sortant de tenter parfois non non moi je
lui ai fait
le bon communicant ce n'est pas celui
qui essaie d'imposer ses vues à celui
qui le conseillent ils essaient de
prendre en compte la personnalité des
attentes et la vision politique de la
personne qui doit servir ci ne se
substitue pas à le prendre la république
pour lui la protection de sa vie privée
le fait que sa vie privée reste privé
était très très important et je pense
que c'est possible
non après je pense que pour les médias
la vie privée fait aussi partie de la
vie publique et il considère qu'on a le
droit tout savoir ou quasiment tout
savoir sur la vie du président je pense
que ce n'est pas un des meilleurs traits
de l'époque
vraiment je crois que ce n'est pas un
meilleur tri de l'époque et je crois
qu'il faut pas s'y résigner je crois
qu'on peut quand même conservé un salon
bhr de digues
vous faisiez comment vous avec tout ça
ah ben moi j'avais enfin la ligne de
politique et de communication était très
simple la vie privée doit rester privé
donc on n'a jamais parlé de la vie
privée même quand on a vu après un
moment julie gayet faire 4e une de paris
match ont à peu près un an autant que
sophie marceau ça c'était quelque chose
qui était un peu ça n'a pas été gérée à
belize ça n'a pas été j'ai réalisé
d'accord c'était c'était elle ok alors
je parle d'autre chose
vous avez déjà commenté qui était le
livre de gérard davet et fabrice lhomme
à la produit évidemment ça a été alors
c'est pas tellement une faute de
communication c'est plutôt il faut enfin
du président de la république voilà qui
n'aurait pas dû parler vous vous avez
dit que le livre était plutôt pas mal
vous l'avait défendu livre vous avez
ajouté qu'il aurait fallu mieux
contrôler la façon dont ce livre a été
édité réalisé par l'éditeur et les
journalistes
on a envie de se dire comment on peut
contrôler la balle entre livre ex
éditorialiste et pas les journalistes
c'est mal dit en tout cas on n'a pas
assez défendu certainement et moi
personnellement la démarche en elle même
parce que la démarche est bonne parler
en vérité les journalistes qui sont plus
supposé de parmi les plus redoutables de
la place de paris redoutable journaliste
d'investigation était redoutable
c'est sympa ça montre qu'on a rien à
cacher et qu'on pense que la
transparence est un élément fondamental
de la démocratie
après je pense qu'il ya eu quelque chose
qui biaise vraiment le raisonnement
c'est le titre du bouquin puits sapele
un président devrait va lire ça qui ne
correspond pas aux
oui ivre si le livre s'était appelé
françois hollande en vérité je pense
qu'on n'aurait pas eu du tout la même
lecture au sens propre comme au sens
figuré
ça c'est sûr le livre en lui-même alors
du coup sûr mieux est ce que ça aurait
pu être aussi que françois hollande
réagissent aux livres c'est vrai qu'il
n'a jamais ford a l'impression qu'il a
pris la déferlante de manière va dire
complètement passive qu'il a subi ce
livre c'est une question que je me suis
souvent posé on conseille souvent posée
la réalité c'est que le cadrage
médiatique était tellement négatif à ce
moment là qu en réalité ça l'aurait
placé lui en position de commentateurs
de telle ou telle petite phrase ça je ne
suis pas sûr que c'était souhaitable
bon après c'est mon intuition peut-être
que je peux me tromper là aussi en
revanche je pense que collectivement
nous c'est à dire ses conseillers ses
ministres les parlementaires de la
majorité peut être d'autres nous aurions
peut-être dû monter davantage au front
pour le défendre
mais la réalité l'école c'est que
derrière ce livre n'est pas une question
de communication média question
politique s'est cristallisée sur ce
livre face à nombre d'oppositions et de
dissensions à l'intérieur de la majorité
et le livre a finalement été plus quatre
textes il a été un prétexte pour avoir
une explication finale avec le président
la république est peut-être l'empêcher
de se présenter
alors justement en question suivante est
ce que c'est à cause de ces livres qui
ne s'est pas présenté parce que c'est un
élément dans la le paysage plus large de
cette famille et 2016 pour moi l'élément
déterminant il n'est pas médiatique ou
elite horyaal livresque ou quoi ou quoi
qu'est ce
non je crois que les monts fondamental
c'est que la gauche était extrêmement
divisée par tissot si c'était
extrêmement divisée et que le progrès
public qu'on dise à considérer je sais
pas à tort ou à raison qu'il n'était
plus en mesure de rassembler toute la
famille socialistes et toute la gauche
et que c'est pour ça qu'ils pouvaient
pas se représenter
alors il ya eu des conseils j'ai lu là
dans un récent article du monde des
hollandais historique 1 qui dresse la
liste de ceux qui ont poussé françois
hollande à ne pas se représenter
ségolène royal jean-pierre mignard et
vous même tiens tiens que des pros
macron ajoute-t-il
que leur répondez vous j'imagine que ce
sont des propos qui sont pas tenus sous
couvert d'anonymat
non donc on sent le courage incroyables
de ces gens qui qui accuse son propre
stade sur moi j'ai découvert le
la décision du prendre un public on a
tout sous des draps ligne droite j'ai
respecté son choix mais à un moment où
sa décision était prise depuis
représenter ou pas dissuadé comme je lui
ai toujours dit c'est sa responsabilité
que c'était sa responsabilité de décider
s'il devait être candidat ou pas parce
que c'était à lui de voir s'il avait en
lui la force nécessaire pour vous
conseiller pas quelqu'un comme vous a
conseillé anc moi j'avais ma conviction
personnelle c'était quoi
dans ma conviction personnelle c'est que
c'était le mieux placé pour porter les
couleurs de la gauche à l'élection
présidentielle qui fait mal présentés
c'était ma conviction personnelle au
moment après c'était lui de décider
il a pris sa décision et je le respecte
et alors concernant votre entre
guillemets patins on va dire en matière
de communication il ya quelque chose qui
a été assez marquant avec votre arrivée
à l'elysée ce sont les interviews
données par le président de la
république il ya eu les commémorations a
effectivement mais ça c'était aussi ceux
des lanceurs aussi largement voilà
lancés à a lancé avant vous et puis
aussi dans des interviews données à des
médias atypique un chasseur français du
lists haïti supplément sur canal + vous
voulez vous en montrer un petit extrait
alors une émission très commenté à
l'époque françois hollande fête ses
trois ans à l'elysée et à cette occasion
il discute avec des jeunes en plateau au
menu un dieudonné qui défraie la
chronique et une grande opération de
pédagogie dont on se cachait de rire
d'eux j'ai donné doit-on avoir honte de
démêler spectacle de dieudonné
on doit réfléchir au riz parfois bien
sûr ceux qui vont grille mais au doigt
ça va qu'est-ce qui lui vous ferrez
pourquoi on rit de ça
c'est marrant de dire que chacun a son
opinion sur eux oui mais quand faire une
blague ça n'a pas fait rire tout entière
certaines personnes et a dopé mais quand
il se déguise en en allemand en asie et
qui dit qu'il faut que des juifs c'est
drôle il ya dès aujourd'hui même des des
chrétiens des musulmans qui se font tuer
dans des conditions horribles
même si c'est pas des génocides c'est
des massacres horribles mais remonte à
l'audience non pas parce qu a eu 6
millions oui je reconnais il narre sa
race une marque tout en diminuant ses
magies mer c'est pas pareil c'est pas
pareil qu'est ce qui était la solution
finale c'est de les tuer tous voilà
enfin je trouve que c'est un très grand
moment de télévision enfin c'est un
moment vraiment rare qu'est loin de la
république pour le coup descendre dans
l'arène à aller au dialogue direct avec
des français en l'occurrence des
adolescents des bientôt adultes pour
affronter vraiment le débat pour de vrai
sur des questions qui sont extrêmement
difficiles l'identité l'antisémitisme le
racisme et ça je crois qu'après
république est dans son rôle quand il va
jusque là parce que derrière les gens
peuvent s'identifier aussi se dire de
prendre la république fait cette
démarche de débat d'écouté de conviction
et donc chacun peut s'interroger aussi
sur celle qu'il doit mener à son tour
vis-à-vis les adolescents à l'aune de ce
qu'on dit aujourd'hui de ce qu'on entend
aujourd'hui on va dire c'est pas trés
jupitérien ça fait pas très président de
la vème république de débattre comme ça
d'égal à égal et le des jeunes qui lui
assure mais je pense que maintenant ce
qu'il dit alors la fonction
présidentielle je pense qu'il ya deux
dimensions d'une dimension extrêmement
verticale correspond à l'entrée en
guerre aux attentats aux crises dans ce
cas là vraiment il faut incarner aux
commémorations
car mais l'histoire la fonction et puis
les moments plus d'horizontalité des
changes direct chaque pilote est souvent
cité comme le principal
conseiller de françois mitterrand était
président de la république extrêmement
jupitérien gestion rationnelle et le
moment aussi de très grande proximité
quand il va avoir directement des
ouvrier dans une usine ou alors quand
ils partent à caen il participe à
l'émission spéciale avec yves menée dans
les années 80 mais mitterrand et au
convoi il mourut this s'asseoir sur le
bureau de vente prévoit république c'est
pas trés jupitérien ça non plus il faut
savoir faire les deux et puis d'autre
part sur le choix des médias
je crois que aujourd'hui faut pas
considérer qu'il ya simplement quelques
grandes chaînes de télévision quelques
grands quotidiens et quelques grandes
radios
je crois qu'ils le paysage médiatique
est de plus en plus éclatées spécialisée
avec des médias de niche et si on veut
s'adresser à tout le monde il faut
savoir s'exprimer sur les médias
différents à la fois pour toucher tout
le monde mais aussi pour surprendre
créer de la tension recréer de
l'attention et ce qui m'intéresse c'est
que aujourd'hui où là vous avez fait le
choix de me parler d'émissions de
suppléments vous n'avez pas fait le
choix d'où par les heat à vous du 14
juillet de tf1 de france 2 pourquoi
parce qu'il ya eu d'autres récits assez
classiques mais décalés bien sûr parce
qu'on se souvient justement cette image
d'un président à qui débat d'égal à égal
avec des jeunes bat le rappel un autre
moment du quinquennat un autre débat
avec un autre jeune une autre jeunesse
débat par médias interposés il n'était
pas là à l'époque voilà alors vous
propose d'écouter la fin du commentaire
de franck louvrier pour qui ce fut une
des grosses erreurs du quinquennat puis
il ya aussi un bon outil qui trouve
yahia linden voilà c'est à dire son top
et son flop du quinquennat on regarde le
plus grand succès c'est que il a réussi
de façon assez calculé
voir passer le relais à son secrétaire
général adjoint
quel est son ministre des finances ce
qui n'est pas rien en termes de
responsabilité pendant cinq ans donc
voilà donc je pense que ça c'est sans
doute un bon coup de com au delà d'être
un bon coup politique
et puis la pia à y en a deux la première
ça a été les veinards bas on a eu
l'impression que c'était un président
qui n'était plus président il fallait
qu'ils restent dans la réponse qui
devait apporter au cas particulier mais
aux principes généraux c'est à dire
quelle position doit avoir face à telle
situation
et là il s'est mis à répondre à un cas
particulier et il fut dirait sur la
forme ça sans doute été l'île de sein je
considère que cette image a été sans
doute l'illustration de tous ses échecs
escape a aussi quelque part une
symbolique qui échappent qui dépasse
l'image parce que nous sommes il est des
gens mouillé oui bien sûr c'est ce que
j'explique que ses collaborateurs
mais malheureusement c'est parce qu'on a
retenue on a retenu un président qui
étaient totalement perdus
sur l'île en pleine tempête et ces
images là sont toujours plus forte que
tout le reste c'est à dire la tempête
c'était bien sûr la tempête économique
la tempête politique dans laquelle il
était et ça a été l'illustration ça
était peut-être la caricature mais c'est
une image qui n'a fait que surligner le
contexte politique dans lequel il était
c'était l'homme impuissant face à la
tempête effectif c'est l'homme
impuissance face à la tempête seul homme
impuissant face au chômage et c'est ça
en fin de compte cette image voilà les
tops et des flops du par franck louvrier
un commentaire à faire a lâché la
première chose c'est que j'ai quand je
suis arrivé à l'elysée moi j'ai entendu
beaucoup de bien de de franck louvrier
les journalistes l'apprécier quasi
unanimement parce qu'il avait une grande
qualité si qui répondait toujours à tous
les appels quoi qu'il arrive laissez
jamais un appel sans réponse ça je
prends sein de conseils implicite dont
j'ai bénéficié et je vois que c'est un
très bon conseil après moi j'ai pas
commenter des choses les unes après les
autres candidats sur lequel non non non
je de choses sur la sur l'île de sein là
pour le coup vraiment je ne serais pas
d'accord avec lui
je crois que c'est l'image était très
belle le président décide de pas
s'abriter parce que tout le monde prend
la pluie devant lui il est respectueux
vis-à-vis des anciens combattants des
deux seins qu'aurait-on dit si c'était
me souviens augmentant sa devient
l'emblème de l'impuissance oui oui mises
d'accord mais c'est pas parce que les
médias sont fainéants qu'il faut
forcément les noms l'or dans leurs
centres dont une image qui lui a fait du
tarn et tant pis non mais je regarde les
choses concrètement si cet art fair est
ce qu'il faudrait que lui se protègent
sous un parapluie dans tous les autres
sont sous la pluie non et alors sur le
succès est là pour le coup c'est la
fameuse incarné par ces images du 8 mai
où françois hollande symboliquement
transmet le flambeau à emmanuel macron
alors là une belle image pour françois
hollande qui finalement à un héritier ce
qu'il dit
cette image vous l'avez travailler elle
a été réfléchi avec penser avec françois
hollande
de votre côté train de s'organiser donc
il faut quand même être quand même son
de raideurs républicaine mais de l'autre
côté au fond pas faire comme s'il ne se
connaissaient pas ils se connaissent ils
s'apprécient qu'ils ont travaillé
ensemble ils ont même certainement
partager des dîners et déjeuners
ensemble ya quelques années ils ont pas
les mêmes
et surtout ému macron s'est présentée de
façon totalement autonome est bon c'est
patrice donc on va faire comme s'ils ne
se connaissaient pas donc j'allais
trouver ce juste équilibre
c'est toujours ce qui est le plus
difficile c'est de trouver un équilibre
une ligne de crête entre solidité et
proximité c'est pas le plus simple
et je crois qu'ils y sont arrivés à pau
ce conseil c'est être le plus naturel
possible et donc françois hollande comme
ça quand il met la main sur l'épaule des
manises pense que c'est pas calculer
c'est pas qu'elle pense que ça lui vient
parce qu'on pense à françois hollande
qui disait il m'a trahi avec méthode
mais c'est incroyable que naturellement
ce soit ça qui lui viennent mais est ce
qu'on est sûr qu'il ait dit ça c'est des
propos qui sont rapportés
j'en sais rien il l'a dit ou pas je sais
pas en tout cas moi je n'ai pas vu
content de vous avez pas entendu dire ça
d'accord alors on va terminer l'émission
parlons un petit peu de vous alors
conseiller en communication normalement
comme l'avait enseigné jacques pilhan
c'est un métier de l'ombre alors vous
vous êtes apparu dans la lumière à la
première fois dans le documentaire
d'yves jeuland tourné à l'elysée je
propose d'en voir un petit extrait suivi
du commentaires d'yves jeuland là je dis
clairement je risque présent par le rap
amsalem a annoncé samedi qu'il va
vouloir dire à un moment où ça va être
facile que le président a demandé contre
une liste de s'exprimer au 20 heures le
soir il faut trouver la bonne façon de
faire la chose mais je pense que c'est
un personnage important du film c'est
pas le personnage principal il ya un
effet loupe un effet d'optique qui fait
que comme c'est un personnage qui était
dans l'ombre et honnêtement avant mon
film on ne le voyait pas tant que ça oui
après on l'avait su cacher et le fait
qu'il soit hors champ des caméras et qui
deviennent un des personnages de mon
film le spectateur va s'intéresser cet
effet d'optique qui fait qu'on a
l'impression ce qui a fait dire au
président la république qui est cet
homme avec des lunettes à côté de
gaspard ganzer en parlant de lui-même
bien sûr c'était une boutade le
président reste le personnage principal
mais oui tout d'un coup ils étaient un
petit peu dans la lumière
certains diront à ses dépens mais tout
dépend du regard du spectateur onu
téléspectateurs on a mis un port un
point important il en avait c'est que
l'hypothèse première qui circulent et
c'est celle d'un traitement de cas
individuels
tu vois ce que je veux dire retraité
pierre paul ou jacques
et le président lui a voulu que ce soit
le lançant d'une presque lui ai dit que
c'était vraiment l'occasion
peux tu vois c'est important parce que
ça n'allait pas de soi même c'est
qu'elle n'allait pas de soi de virer
tout le monde de demander la démission
de tout le monde ça je pense que
personne ne s'y attendait c'est
évidemment ce qu'il fallait faire depuis
que le temps politique est esclave du
temps médiatique
les conseillers en communication sont
devenus des coursiers prépondérant je
dirais même que gaspard ganzer qu'il le
veuille ou non qui même si dit le
contraire que c'est le conseiller
principal de françois hollande
y'a pas un déplacement ou gaspard n'est
pas là il lui est devenu indispensable
vous qui l'avez suivi donc ils n'en
veulent pas les journalistes mais c'est
un peu l'homme qui murmure à l'oreille
des journalistes et des pistes dans une
relation de séduction c'est ce qu'ont
oui c'est un grand séducteur eu bien sûr
mais il n'est jamais dans la lah aussi
beaucoup de pudeur je pense qu'il a
contredisait peu souvent le trop
peut-être contredisait trop peu je pense
le chef de l'état mais je suis pas sûr
de moi là dessus mais je crois qu'il ya
quand même
comme françois hollande gaspard guerre
n'est pas un homme de conflit
le conseiller principal et suscite des
jalousies
mais qui contredit peu trop peu françois
hollande peut-être parce qu'il n'est pas
un homme de conflit alors conseiller
principal non plus n'avait d'autres qui
étaient plus importants que moi
considère climatique le secrétaire
général de l'elysée il ya celui que ça
finalement
un regard surtout quoi c'est ça oui je
voyais beaucoup de choses mais j'étais
pas le principal j'étais un des
principaux est on est on est et d'autre
on était une équipe ça c'est la première
chose
la deuxième chose c'est que la
contradiction et reprendra république
qu'elle souhaitait jamais devant les
caméras oui mais vous disiez vous même
tout à l'heure au début de l'interview
de contre et ici j'ai pas sur la courbe
a surtout je sais pas si si si je disais
toujours ce que je pensais j'ai toujours
dit exactement ce que je pensais au
président de république et on n'a
souvent pas été d'accord mais ça c'est
la vie ces huit chefs d'accord et vous
par exemple sur quoi maintenant il ya
prescription non c'est fini
hanoi aura jamais de prescription là
dessus jallet prescription sur ce que
vous lui avez jusqu'à ce qu'il ce que je
lui ai conseillé qu'il a suivi ça on
peut en parler on en a parlé d'ailleurs
des émissions qui sont en revanche les
conseils que je donne et qui n'a pas
suivi que ça lui appartient je vous
communiquerai jamais battu et les
conseils que vous lui donnez vous l'avez
donné qu'il a suivi et dont vous n'êtes
pas fier après coup le regret ou là
ces mutations ont en tout cas là on a un
peu laissé entendre moi c'est vrai qu'à
la suite du livre de dave et l'homme
j'étais plutôt partisan de ne pas monter
au front tout de suite d'attendre de
voir comment les choses se passaient et
caetera et peut-être qu'on aurait dû
monter au front plus vite voilà ça
pourrait être un regret ouais voilà
plein d'autres mais je pense à celui ci
je pense qu'on aurait dû se battre
davantage et pour ce maillot de macron à
qui a été un peu finalement l'antithèse
pour l'instant de de françois hollande
on voit que vous vous avez beaucoup vers
la transparence beaucoup vers l'élysée
aux journalistes un bon rapport avec les
journalistes comme françois hollande
s'est pas tellement le début de la
présidence macro et il ya eu dès les
premiers jours cette lettre un des
journalistes lettre ouverte qui
s'insurge que le président l'aiguiser
veuille choisir les journalistes qui
accompagnent le président etc
ils ont raison de s'inquiéter des
journalistes enfin je crois qu'il ya un
début de quinquennat il ya des petits
ajustements qui seront dans la relation
entre le pouvoir présidentiel et la
crèche sûr qu'ils vont trouver un mode
easy jet lundi à saly pas inquiet parce
que les petits réglages relais il veut
tout contrôler non c'est pas ça
oh non je crois pas du tout qu'il
respecte l'indépendance des médias donc
alors pour terminer bon il ya très
commentée a été votre candidature
pendant 24 heures aux élections
législatives à voilà sous la bannière en
marche alors vous avez expliqué qu
emmanuel macron que vous avez pas
vraiment sollicité un c'est ce qu'on a
compris depuis que vous avez été
candidat pendant pendant 24 heures en
matière de communication c'était pas
super finalement d'être candidat puis de
retirer sa candidature annoncée on bosse
on peut pas dire on pourrait dire que ce
soit une réussite
sauf peut-être la seule satisfaction
qu'on peut avoir c'est peut-être la
candidature la plus éphémère de
l'histoire de la république 24 ans je
suis pas sûr que les gens étaient
candidats si peu de temps dans
l'histoire
donc ça me fera un record de plus si je
vais peut-être le seul que j'aurais
jamais de toute ma vie
non c'était pas brillant honnêtement les
choses sont allées très vite j'ai mis 24
heures pour répondre à la proposition
qui m'avaient été faites
j'ai dit non au final parce que
franchement je pense que c'était pas du
tout une bonne idée je pense que c'est
parce que j'aurais fait mieux dans ma
vie de ses 24 ans en fait c'est à dire
qu'en fait ils ont pensé à vous vous
avez t'expliquer voilà votre nom a
circulé
voilà l'équipe dans marche âgées
patients dire non tout de suite j'ai pas
su dire non tout de suite en disant
vraiment c'est pas une bonne idée je ne
sens pas faut pas le faire et cetera
parce que certainement j'étais quand
même toucher ou honoré
que cette idée puisse circuler j'ai eu
24 heures pour remettre les choses
d'aplomb dans ma tête et après avoir
parlé des trams et les autres avec les
uns avec les autres
je me dis non franchement c'était pas
mon tour c'est intéressant sur le temps
à retrouver être maître des horloges
prendre le temps de réfléchir et à 24
heures
cc c'est trop pour les médias ce que
saab se fait il faut il vous faudrait
agir en instantané aussi oui c'est vrai
que les médias vont de plus en plus vite
il accroît doivent faire attention il
faut il faut de plus en plus mais
attention toutefois il faut pas
confondre l'éphémère de la rapidité
médiatique avec la trace longue et un
pour finir vous lasserez guillemets la
trace que vous voudrez à l'essai en tant
que communiquant à l'elysée puisque vous
quittez là vous allez partir d'autres
d'abord très difficile en tout cas moi
ma passion c'est la conviction la
pédagogie essayer d'expliquer ce qu'on
fait je pense que je suis pas toujours
arriver mais en tout cas j'ai toujours
essayé de le faire c'est parce qu'il ya
un documentaire qui en témoignent bon
bah merci beaucoup merci le projet
la façon dont ces disposer pour le
compense pas aux caméras à ce que la
plupart du temps vous faites après tout
même à les entretiens les entretiens
sont toujours l'extérieur toujours soit
dans le giro mais c'est beaucoup mieux
[Musique]